i want to turn briefly to the last four
days of the platinum jubilee sharon
because
aside from boris johnson being booed
which may well have been a tipping point
for many mps to press the button on him
today with this no confidence uh it was
also interesting to me that the sussexes
got booed
uh harry and megan what did you make of
that well it wasn't a total boom it
wasn't as big as boris no nowhere near
very unusual for a member of the royal
family to get any booing at that kind of
event and they did but it wasn't
anywhere near as bad as boris you could
still hear the cheers above the booze
put it that way
i mean what should we read much into it
i just got the feeling they basically
discovered on this particular trip that
they've gone from a-list royals to
c-list and that's how the royal family
are now going to treat them they won't
be on the balcony they won't be at the
top events and they can come and go if
they want but they're no longer going to
be
working a-list important royalties
they have lost their importance they
don't mean anything the country um
wasn't that overjoyed i didn't hear many
people go this is amazing the country
really cares right he didn't and and the
thing that i must say is the country
didn't react one way or the other it was
oh they're here okay
but
the way they kind of came in and went
was
a huge signal that i don't think we'll
see them here much and what made me
laugh is they they arrived on a massive
private jet from california these two
eco worries constantly preach well we'll
fight it'll be i mean
it'll come out if you've zelda's a lot
they've used the clooneys a lot who know
if somebody right but it's the utter
hypocrisy once again preaching about
carbon footprint always using private
jets every time so
i mean funny enough is the common link
between all the people who got booed was
hypocrisy the british public will
forgive a lot of things but they won't
forgive brazen hypocrisy to be fair on
them they did actually keep a relatively
low profile they didn't say
you know you said they discovered their
c list i mean they asked to be taken off
the list you know they
wanted to be out of the working
circulation so i i think it could have
gone worse you know i don't think they
overshadowed it no no they didn't people
took pictures of them but they did
behave quite well what was the new
impact i wanted no impact i just want to
play a clip first of all of the this is
the queen on the last the closing
moments
of the platinum jubilee on sunday
because we weren't sure if she'd even
make it she was there at the start i was
by the palace when they when she came
out on the thursday it was amazing
moment and then she just sort of
vanished from sight and we thought that
maybe we wouldn't see her again and then
you suddenly saw the flag moving
on the palace roof and you realized
fantastic and then you thought go on
how'd you come and out came the star of
the show the star of any show she's ever
at and she came out and i just thought
if we can listen to a bit of the sound
here i just thought this was
so moving
it gives you goosebumps it really does
[Applause]
that was a scene and then of course the
crowd had burst into god save the queen
which was incredibly evocative and
emotional i felt um isabel i mean
it's hard to overstate the importance of
this queen to this country or the impact
that we're gonna have when she's no
longer here couldn't agree more i mean i
found i'm not a massive monarchist but i
found the whole thing weirdly moving and
it is because it sort of feels like it's
a bit of a goodbye
i know that sounds a little bit more kid
what's the last do you believe that we
better have for her in reality she is
not well we know that and you know when
the palace says she's experiencing some
discomfort we know that really means
she's in a very great deal of pain and i
think when she does sadly pass there is
going to be a huge amount of national
soul-searching yeah i agree you know she
has held everything together real
concerns about the future of the union
and the commonwealth i totally agree
grace i know you're not a massive
monarchist in fact you spent most of the
weekend
according to your instagram feed at a
wild festival where you were painting
your fingernails fluorescent green
you're not a fan which i thought was a
tribute the queen wore actually on the
sunday night
clearly
but even as somebody's not that into the
monarchy can you appreciate what this
woman has done for the country
i have basically no opinions about them
as people i don't really follow you know
the ins and outs of the monarchy i don't
think i should have to follow what goes
on within this family this dynasty that
kind of rules our country from behind
the scenes what i do think though is
that when the queen does sadly die we
will enter into a national conversation
about whether or not this is an
institution that we should have as part
of our you know constitution as part of
the way that our country works it is
very strange that we have a family whose
you know uh marriages weddings births
dramas we're all constantly invested in
understanding as though they're they're
kind of kardashians or something that
they're in charge of our politics of our
government ultimately this is our head
of state i think that when the queen who
everyone you know loves and who's been
in charge for a very long time uh does
go and we have this array of pretty
uninspiring potential successes people
are going to start thinking
this is what we really want right you
are missing in my view the rising
superstar of the royal family and it's
this little guy he is louis he's amazing
who whose facial expressions over the
four days got increasingly hilarious
and who clearly began to seize his
moment and in fact the duke and duchess
of cambridge issued a statement tonight
on twitter thanking everybody and saying
that we all had a fantastic time
especially louie
[Laughter]
don't you think though that it it gave
people confidence that this is the
family that will be here after the queen
yeah by the way very deliberately that
last scene on the last night and
everyone was singing god save the queen
but she had chosen for that sort of
iconic moment at the end of the
picture that this was the family she
that this is now the streamlining
these are the two next monarchs
potentially three next monarchs and
that's the way it will be charles has
said for a long time that he's going to
cut down the people who are actually on
payroll and that represent the family
it's going to be cold and the thing is
i i think that the royal family brings
so much to this country
i mean you look at all the
people from all over the tourists i mean
i think they're touring
they don't actually cost us anything the
merchants the greatest myth
i think if we were going to make a kind
of coherent economic argument as to how
we construct our head of state we could
probably make a better one for saying i
don't know have a presidential system or
have one got our own version of joe
biden well i mean no it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be the same as that you would
have just putting it out here